bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin pour le débat
politique d'ayrté france alors le pass
vaccinale a été adopté dans la nuit au
sénat avec pas mal de modifications
il est obligatoire pour les plus de 18
ans à présent un seuil de dix mille
malades dans les hôpitaux pour pouvoir
le mettre en place pas de contrôles
d'identité non plus pour les
restaurateurs qu'en pensez-vous je
commence par vous alexander nikolic
oui d'avoir juste sur les modifications
ou et la droite c'est un peu adaptée au
sénat pour pas déplaire aux
restaurateurs et pas les forcer à faire
des contrôles ça va dans ça va dans le
bon sens mais nous on est contre
évidemment se passe parce que ce qui est
raisonnable aujourd'hui c'est de
constater qu' il n'y a pas de
avec la vaccination une grande
diminution de la contamination au regard
du nombre de gens qui sont qui sont
contaminés alors qu'on le croyait au
début moi le premier on a on a vraiment
plus grand quand on vaccine en plus les
jeunes on allait on allait vraiment
limiter la contamination c'est pas le
cas il faut évidemment ciblées avec un
vaccination ceux qui peuvent avoir des
formes graves et dire les personnes
âgées les personnes qui ont des maladies
qui peuvent entraîner un passage en
réanimation ou qui évidemment à mourir
et ça doit être l'objectif raisonnable
aujourd'hui constate le nombre de
personnes qui sont contaminées dans le
pays on a on s'est trompé un petit peu
au départ moi même j je le dis j'y ai
cru donc voilà donc c'est aussi le rôle
des politiques de s'adapter et donc de
cibler les bonnes personnes parce que
évidemment ce qui est doit être
l'objectif c'est de limiter les places
en réanimation
surtout parce qu'on n'a pas augmenté le
nombre de places
de lits de réanimation et donc on est
toujours coincé avec à peu près 45 50
places en moyenne par département
mythe c'est bien ça c'est bien la limite
c'est ce fameux curseur déplace à
l'hôpital et les sénateurs ont voulu
mettre une un curseur justement de dix
mille personnes à l'hopital pour mettre
en place ce pass vaccinale eric azière
il fallait mettre justement ce curseur
en tout cas je crois déjà on a assisté à
un exercice démocratique
puisque le sénat a amendé le projet du
gouvernement est que aujourd'hui va se
tenir la commission mixte paritaire qui
va permettre sans doute de faire une
synthèse entre le projet de loi et les
amendements qui ont été débattus cette
nuit au sénat et d
en un petit point du procès et que les
rôles de deux institutions assemblée
nationale et c'est là bon sur un sujet
qui est extrêmement compliqué et on
viens de l'entendre extrêmement complète
vont permettre de
212 faire une synthèse qui tiendra
compte de toutes les influences
politiques pour arriver à la mise en
oeuvre se passe sanitaire qui est une
nécessité absolue qui est l'état
supplémentaire après le pass vaccinale
pourquoi d'abord parce qu'ils incitent à
la vaccination or vous voulez de
reconnaître qu' il fallait évidemment
cibler les les personnels à risque en ce
qui concerne la serre et ciblée du tout
entre autres en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence si
il ya déjà
toutes les personnes âgées toutes les
personnes qui présentent des des dangers
une commune co co morbidités
qui pourrait les amener à suivre une
dans le processus de la maladie une
aggravation définitive mais en
l'occurrence il s'agit aussi de
d'adapter le pass sanitaires à
différents publics et en particulier à
celui des enfants et du personnel
éducatif et donc okala à nos riches y
semant du projet qui s'est produit cette
nuit et qui me paraît tout à fait
nécessaire qu'on fixe un seuil
aujourd'hui à 10000 hospitalisé pour la
mise en oeuvre du passani terre est une
première mesure d'exemption mais en
l'occurrence nous signale qu aujourd'hui
on est à plus de 21000 hospitalisé ce
qui veut dire que en cas de vague de
vagues épidémiques commente celle qu'on
est enfin de vivre on est dans quelque
chose qui permet peut-être
éventuellement d'avoir un tableau de
bord de la bague et qui permettent
d'adapter le niveau d'exigence dupas
sanitaire au niveau d'aggravation de la
vague épidémique ce donc je crois qu'on
on est là dans un exercice qui me paraît
être au fond un juste juste synthèse un
juste milieu et en tant que centriste
c'est une position que j'affectionne
particulièrement entre le provenait du
gouvernement et puis le débat
démocratique et lieux et qui a permis à
toutes les sensibilités politiques
en tout cas au sénat d'amender le projet
et j'espère qu'aujourd'hui la commission
mixte paritaire permettra d'arriver à
quelque chose qui qu'ils soient le plus
adapté possible si c'était simple de
mettre en oeuvre une politique sanitaire
depuis deux ans ça sort et en
l'occurrence est compliqué le chapeau
aujourd'hui jean michel blanquer me
paraît un petit peu lourd et un petit
peu en parlent en parler je vais je vais
je vous interromps parce que j'aimerais
bien qu'on vous entende tout les 2 75%
de grévistes effectivement aujourd'hui
jeudi noir attendus dans l'est dans les
établissements scolaires les parents
d'élèves qui soutiennent aussi les profs
contre ces protocoles sanitaires
imposées par le gouvernement ont-ils
raison alexander nico leach ses
enseignants et ses parents d'élèves de
sortir dans la rue aujourd'hui pour
protester
oui ils ont ils ont raison
comme comme presque tous les parents je
l' ai vécu j'ai vécu lundi j'ai eu mon
fils de qui va bientôt quatre ans va
faire son test pcr on a attendu trois
heures dans le froid beaucoup de parents
n'ont même pas pu avoir de rendez vous
parce que ça a été très mal anticipé
face à ce constat le gouvernement a
décidé le soir même
le premier ministre d'annoncer des
nouvelles mesures en disant qu'on va
passer à des autotests et qui aura des
attestations sur l'honneur des parents
ils n'ont même pas prévenu le personnel
qui de l'éducation nationale donc ni les
instituteurs ni les atsem qui se sont
retrouvés complètement dépourvu quand le
matin même le lendemain matin par dont
les parents sont venus alors dix ans
mais où sont les attestations sur
l'honneur et qu'est ce qu'on va faire
exactement et eux mêmes n'étaient pas
n'était pas au courant qu il ya eu un
vrai problème en terme de communication
avec le avec tout le personnel ce qui
ramené détention etc les professeurs les
instits et atsem qu'ont dû subir ces
tensions et donc il ya un manque de
préparation
une adaptation très lente et c'est
exactement pareil quand je parle d'un
aussi d'un manque d'anticipation parce
que on a on voit que que le gouvernement
a décidé lundi encore de
faire en sorte que les enfants ne
sortent qu'à la sortie casque à 16h30
pardon ne sorte qu'à la fermeture des
écoles pourquoi parce qu'ils sont rendu
compte que quand il avait un protocole
qui devait faire de 40 sorte que tous
les parents viennent chercher les
enfants dans la journée qu'il y avait un
cas positif et bien ça poserait un
problème parce que les gens travaillent
et 7 ce manque de visibilité sur le
terrain et ne pas avoir pensé en amont
ça allait causer un vrai problème c'est
quand même très inquiétant de voir un
gouvernement qui est à ce point couper
du terrain et qui ne comprend pas que ce
que les protocoles qui avait été mis en
place allez forcément poser problème et
donc ils réagissent parce que les gens
râlent ça devait se prévoir en amont
alors justement les gens rail vous dites
il ya une mouvement cet après midi à
partir de 14h ou d'ampleur inédite a
priori eric azière comme le jean michel
blanquer redis on ne fait pas grève
contre contre un virus vous en pensez
quoi
oh je pense que jean michel blanquer
étant dans une position extrêmement
difficile il faut dire les choses
clairement c'est pas très facile il a en
charge un projet éducatif au nom de
l'exécutif est
entravé par par des contraintes qui est
de mettre en place une politique
sanitaire c'est pas là on a vu cette ce
protocole sanitaire se mettre en place
le dimanche la veille de la rentrée
quand même un minimum d'anticipation
d'ailleurs vous avez raison s'il
s'agissait d'un seul au total sanitaires
mais depuis le 2 janvier on est à trois
protocoles sanitaires avec tout ce qui
tout ce qu'il faut pour essayer
d'alléger ce protocole parce que au fur
et à mesure qu'on l'appliqué on
s'aperçoit que c'est difficile voire
c'est impossible et je compatis avec un
extérieur des comics comme parent v
comme comme anciens anciens parents mes
enfants sont plus grands mais parce que
c'est évidemment extrêmement compliqué
le gouvernement a choisi de maintenir en
quelque sorte ce contrôle dans les
écoles et l'ouverture des écoles y
répond avec deux priorités la première
priorité c'est de maintenir des enfants
à l'école parce que parce que l'on s'est
aperçu à quel point les dégâts pouvait
important dans la fermeture des écoles
dans l'interruption de ceux de ce
processus de déduire et du quel type de
transmission du savoir et deuxièmement
parce que en tant que parents et ça
vient d'être dit par monsieur nikolic en
tant que parent évidemment ça permet aux
parents de continuer à travailler pour
pour ceux pour qui cet indispensable et
donc en l'occurrence de maintenir le
pays en activité donc il s'agit là
aujourd'hui de faire la part des choses
entre eux allez disons le c'est un
certain nombre de technocrates de
l'éducation nationale mais aussi du
gouvernement et aider et 200
fonctionnaires de la santé net au point
comme protocole dans leurs bureaux et
puis la vie pratique de ces trois
publics le monde éducatif les enfants et
les parents et c'est disons le est
extrêmement difficile voilà alors pas
que le gars passionné jean parent aussi
dans l'administration en tout cas pour
marine le pen je vous laisserai répondre
mais regardez pour marine le pen c'est
l'enfer
ce protocole sanitaire à l'école c'est
l'enfer je suis saisi tous les jours par
des parents qui n'en peuvent plus et ont
l'impression de maltraiter leurs enfants
il faut simplifier ce protocole est
arrêté de le changer tous les deux jours
alexandre alexander nicolet et marine le
pen parle d'eux maltraitance ou en tant
que parent vous êtes d'accord avec ce
terme c'est pas un peu excessif
non mais c'est un énorme problème de
devoir s'adapter en permanence de pas
comprendre ce qui se passe encore une
fois et parfois d'avoir
comme je les dis juste avant deux des
instituteurs et des atsem qui n'ont pas
reçu les protocoles
avant la communication officielle donc
ça s'est compliqué pour les parents de
comprendre ce qui se passe est de
s'adapter et puis après vous avez très
concrètement cette politique d'autotest
qui est très difficile à mettre en place
parce que c'est parfois difficile déjà
pour un adulte de d'utiliser un autotest
alors quand vous devez le faire avec un
enfant de 4 5 ans qui a du mal à
comprendre ce qui se passe et qui hurle
et qui qui veut surtout pas le faire il
ya beaucoup de parents qui sont très en
difficulté pour faire ça enfin voilà ça
semble simple sur le papier mais quand
on le fait réellement oui ça peut
s'apparenter presque à de la
maltraitance pour les enfants et et
c'est c'est ça pose évidemment un
problème et et tous les protocoles pour
des enfants très jeunes comme ça qu'ils
ont du mal à comprendre ce qui se passe
c'est complexe surtout quand on sait
qu'il ya très peu d'enfants qui ont des
formes graves voire pas du tout donc on
peut se demander quel est le l'utilité
d'une telle politique par rapport aux
enfants eric azière je repose la
question dans l'autre sens finalement
par rapport à ce que dit alexander
nicolita en tant que parent est ce qu'il
vaut mieux pas protégé les professeurs
et les parents ils savent comment
comment se protéger maintenant face à un
virus qui est moins virulent en plus
je pense que tout ceci va servir
évidemment à arriver mais encore une
fois je le disais tout à l'heure
j'espère que c'est aujourd'hui
que cette issue est possible à la
commission mixte paritaire a quelque
chose qui soit pratique a en effet le
labyrinthe et le foisonnement des tests
des autotests des tests pcr la
difficulté à s'en procurer les queues
devant les pharmacies moi j'observe ça
avec avec un papier et un effroi général
nouveau protocole a priori mais oui il
en reste suffit juste pour kia ce que
j'ai vu hier il en reste encore trop
mais je reconnais qu'il ya là quelque
chose sur lequel
il va falloir améliorer et allégée
terriblement au protocole mais en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence on ne peut
pas non plus exempte est complètement
les enfants est exempté de l'es22 les
méprise il faut continuer à les
préserver des risques de contamination
il faudra toute la journée 1 il faut le
faire il faut le faire en tenant compte
encore une fois de la psychologie des
enfants et c'est vrai que pour beaucoup
d'enfants cette espèce d'interruption de
leur journée avec un coton tige dans le
nez est quelque chose qui qui finit par
devenir véritablement traumatisant le
mot n'est pas trop fort et je pense
qu'il ya la dent encore une fois les
amendements qui ont été votés adopté
cette nuit au sénat qu'ils peuvent
exempté tout un public d'enfants de ces
de ses précautions et de c2c prévention
nos tares être une première démarche
voilà encore une fois si c'était simple
ça serait oui il ya eu des retards en ce
qui concerne la transmission des
protocoles entre l'exécutif et les
directeurs des écoles oui tout ceci
épuisent le monde éducatif et je
comprends aujourd'hui leur colère et
leur manifestation ils manifestent pas
contre le virus c'est là peut-être qu'il
ya un abus de langage de la part du
ministre de l'éducation nationale mais
ils manifestent leur épuisement leur
exaspération comme ça s'est déjà produit
à l'hôpital il ya quelques mois avec les
personnels de santé le mot le monde se
le corps social français soumis à cette
épidémie souffre et exprime ses
souffrances bon il ya
des protocoles pardon assez pour un
équilibre du temps de parole que je vous
interromps difficultés à mettre en place
ces mesures mais les professeurs
dénoncent aussi le manque de main ce qui
avait été promis par le gouvernement les
fameux tests salivaires qui ne sont
toujours pas arrivés dans les écoles qui
pourrait simplifier la situation
alexander nico leach pour vous il ya
aussi
faute du gouvernement sur les promesses
d'approvisionnement
oui c'est ce que disent les
beaucoup d'instituteurs c'est que il y
avait des masques qui devait arriver
qu'ils sont pas arrivés il ya enfin
beaucoup de matériel qui est acquis et
qui avait été promis qu'ils aient n'est
pas n'est pas arrivé mais globalement
quand on dit on doit
vraiment on est obligé de mener cette
politique par rapport aux enfants moi je
pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
s'interroge et qu'on soit presque aussi
un petit peu positif il ya aujourd'hui
il ya quatre cent mille personnes qui
sont contaminées quotidiennement il ya
quelques mois quand il y avait 400 me et
qu'il y avait cent cinquante mille
personnes qui étaient contaminés ça se
ressentait de manière très claire sur
les l'occupation des places de en lits
de réanimation alors moi je constate que
il ya 15-20 personne même pas qui est
qui et qui sont s'ajoutent
quotidiennement en réanimation à ce que
je fais exprès de parler de ce sujet qui
est vraiment essentiel parce que c'est
ce qui conduit systématiquement aux
mesures et pourquoi d'ailleurs parce
qu'on a toujours un nombre de places en
réanimation très faible il n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation à l'aller virus est
virulent
oui c'est justement ça que je voulais
dire c'est que ya un manque d'adaptation
par rapport à par rapport à ça on voit
bien que au micron très concrètement
entraîne moins de deux cas graves et ça
prouve aussi que la vaccination pour les
personnes à risque a été a été quand
même efficace parce qu'on voit moins de
personnes en réanimation donc il faut
continuer vraiment j'insiste à cibler
faut mener une politique sanitaire
intelligente et adaptée aux variants
qu'on a face à nous donc il faut
absolument vacciner les personnes qui
sont à risque pour empêcher pour kiel
pour qu'ils n'aient pas de forme grave
qui les conduisent en réanimation ou
qu'il qu'il décède et et il faut
évidemment augmenter le nombre de places
en réanimation parce que quand je le
rappelle il ya 4000 personnes à peu près
qui sont en réanimation aujourd'hui un
petit peu moins d'ailleurs malgré cette
contamination de 400000 quotidiennement
et bien c'est pourquoi on est coincé par
4000 c'est à peu près 40 en moyenne par
département c'est que dès que vous avez
une petite augmentation du nombre de cas
graves vous êtes tout de suite coincé
parce que vous avez un manque de places
en réanimation qu il qu'on adapte
l'hôpital évidemment à ce type
d'épidémie et qu'on soit capable d'avoir
un peu plus de marge pour pouvoir
prendre des mesures adéquates ce
qui est un peu gênant c'est ce manque
d'adaptation au réel et marion qu'on a
qu'on a face à nous eric azière vous
voulez réagir je voudrais vous faire
réagir je pose ma question ce qui nous
reste deux minutes sur la plupart des
syndicats qui demandent aujourd'hui
aucun cas positif
justifie une fermeture de classe comme
c'était le cas auparavant est-ce que
c'est justifié selon vous dans ce
nouveau contexte de variantes moins
virulent
étant donné la force et le caractère
exponentiel en termes de contagiosité du
variant il me semble qu'à ce rythme là
on va fermer toutes les classes or c'est
justement ce qu'on veut éviter ce qu'on
veut éviter ces c'est ce qui s'est
produit il ya maintenant un an et demi
c'est celle interruption c'est la
fermeture des écoles or vous voyez bien
que au fond on est sûr à sur une
croissance exponentielle
de la contagiosité mais si on se réfère
aux exemples étrangers en particulier
anglo australien et dans un certain
nombre de pays comme israël qui sont
déjà très largement contaminé par le
variant au micron alors on s'aperçoit
qu'on n'est peut-être pas loin du pic
épidémique
et c'est une course contre le temps
qu'on est en train de vivre alors oui la
capacité d'adaptation monsieur des
coliques du gouvernement je pense
qu'elle est très grande la réalité c'est
que la capacité d'adaptation aux
variations de la politique sanitaire du
peuple français du corps social elle et
elle est peut-être aussi un peu moindre
on a peut-être optimiser la la souplesse
du monde éducatif que ce soit les
enfants les parents le personnel
enseignant dans cette affaire mais en
l'occurrence évidemment on cherche à
s'adapter on cherche à faire au mieux
mais en l'occurrence je crois que il y a
véritablement là encore une fois il une
chance d'arriver à quelque chose
d'équilibré oui il y aura eu un
tâtonnement oui c'était un pari
extrêmement difficile et la virulence et
la violence
de deux derniers de la dernière vague
épidémique amis en effet le gouvernement
devant une épreuve l on confie n'ira
dire
plus ou moins bien mais en l'occurrence
malheureusement
merci beaucoup je suis désolé on n'a
plus le temps malheureusement allexant
derniers connaissent de répondre merci à
vous eric mais elle fière d'avoir
répondu et d'avoir participé à ce débat
sur rt france